Приймальня "Лефортово" - в маленькому непримітному провулку Москви.
Кілька місцевих волонтерів привезли
українським морякам речі та продукти.
- Нам заборонили чомусь передавати вівсяні пластівці
і заборонили "Доширак" (локшина - Ред.).
Ну, ще там були імбир та йогурти. Чомусь не можна.
У кожному СІЗО - свої правила, яка логіка в цьому, мені не зрозуміло.
Адвокат Микола Полозов вирушив із заявою
в приймальню ФСБ. Потрапити в "Лефортово"
до свого підзахисного Дениса Гриценка він не зміг.
Адвокат переконаний, що юристів свідомо
не пускають до затриманих.
- Те, що відбувається, інакше як свавіллям
з боку російських посадових осіб, ФСБ не назвеш.
Іде суттєве обмеження права на захист.
Не дають можливості зустрітися з підзахисним.
Звісно, цю ситуацію, боюся, можуть використати
для того, щоб і далі тиснути на військовополонених,
щоб примусити їх дати потрібні слідству свідчення.
Тим часом російські правозахисники
із Громадської спостережної комісії Москви
переконані: 21 моряку, які перебувають в ув'язненні
в "Лефортово", нічого не бракує.
- На умови утримання вони не скаржаться.
Камери карантинні в ізоляторі "Лефортово",
де їх утримують, щойно після ремонту.
Не  менш оптимістично в російській
Громадській спостережній комісії відгукуються
про стан здоров'я трьох українських військовополонених,
які перебувають у лікарні "Матроської тиші".
- Тут, у лікарні, їм усіляко сприяють, їх оглянули
всі лікарі, у них взяли всі аналізи. І сьогодні
одному з моряків, у якого осколкове поранення ноги,
за нашим клопотанням видали палицю.
Волонтер Костянтин Котов кілька разів виходив
на одиночні пікети з вимогою обміну
українських військовополонених на російських:
усіх на всіх.
- Ми виступатимемо, звісно, і за цих моряків.
Мені здається, щодо них завдання дещо простіше:
вони справді військовополонені,
жодних сумнівів у цьому немає. Їх фактично
захопили під час військового конфлікту в Керчі.
Тому, мені здається, перспективи деякі є.
Тим часом волонтери допомогли відправити морякам
перші листи від родичів поштою,
а кримські активісти вже зібрали близько 100 тисяч гривень
та гуманітарну допомогу для українських моряків,
ув'язнених у Росії.